wir sind sehr glücklich üblich und
explodiert von die alten gratulationen
insbesondere aus deutschland jetzt sehr
glücklich über diese wahl sind ab eine
frage möchte ich in den ställen papier
in deutschland gearbeitet gibt es eine
aussicht dass sie vielleicht für beide
usa zurück nach deutschland
ich werde natürlich alles tun
joe biden und kameras zu unterstützen
alles was aber diese ämter besetzung
angeht liegt noch weit weit wir sind
jetzt einfach nur mal äußerst entzückte
robert keller
wir haben uns so häufig in verschiedenen
transatlantischen organisationen
getroffen
wir haben auch so viel zeit in berlin
verbracht wir werden also unabhängig
davon wo ich gerade sollte immer unsere
freundschaft vertreten und fallender das
ist dann die die erste gewinnerin diese
freundschaft der beiden präsidenten joe
biden gut du kennst sein verhältnis zu
deutschland ich glaube du warst mit ihm
in münchen zum beispiel auf der münchner
sicherheitskonferenz was glaubst du wird
joe biden als erstes tun um dieses jahr
durchaus in den letzten jahren
angespannte verhältnis zu deutschland
und zu europa vielleicht wieder zu
stabilisieren
danke dass du die sicherheitskonferenz
zweimal war ich dort in den letzten vier
jahren
du hast recht diese frage zu stellen
nein denn ich glaube was joe biden
beschluss zu tun insbesondere nach
seiner amtseinführung wird große
symbolische bedeutung haben
ich weiß natürlich die antwort auf deine
frage nicht aber ich glaube dass es
einige wichtige schritte ergriffen
werden nicht nur im wort sondern auch in
der tat die noch einmal die bedeutung
der transatlantischen beziehungen
unterstreichen wird
ob das nun die sicherheitskonferenz und
münchen seien oder ob es ein nato gipfel
sein wird oder irgendein anderes forum
das wissen wir noch vieles hängt auch
von kogit ab davon was in anderen
weltgegenden gefühlt aber ich habe schon
ganz viele anzeichen dafür dass die
wichtigkeit der transatlantischen
beziehungen noch mal im all ihrer
entscheidenden bedeutung hervorgehoben
wird
es wird eine sehr viel stärker auf
zusammenarbeit gerichtete beziehung sein
als bisher mit deutschland mit europa
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren